there are many physical problems in
which a body undergoes motion about a
central point and when that happens
there's a natural coordinate system to
describe that motion which in two
dimensions is polar coordinates so let's
consider the orbit of an object for
instance the best example is the
circular orbit we have a circular orbit
of an object there is a central point
which we'll call Pete now given this
type of motion with an object it
naturally makes sense to choose a
coordinate system called polar
coordinates the way that coordinate
system works is as follows first off we
need to choose a reference angle and so
we'll choose a horizontal line and we'll
draw a ray and we'll show a direction of
increasing reference angle theta in this
example theta will go from 0 to 2 pi
along with the reference angle we have a
distance from the central point and that
distance will refer to as R so the
coordinates of our point are R and theta
now the variable R is always greater
than R and can go to infinity greater
than 0 so this is our polar coordinate
system when you have a coordinate system
remember at every point in space there
has to be unit vectors so at this point
right here how do we choose unit vectors
for polar coordinates we always choose
the unit vectors to point in the
increasing direction of the coordinate
take the R coordinate that increases
radially outward so our unit vectors
here will have a R hat pointing radially
outward what about the theta Direction
tangential to the circle in this
particular case because theta is
increasing in this direction we choose
our tangential unit vector which we're
going to call theta hat
which is at right angles to our hat to
point in the direction of increasing
theta and so at this point we now have a
set of unit vectors now one has to be
very careful in polar coordinates for
the following reason
suppose that you're at another point
over here now because we have two
different points let's just give some
names to these points we'll call this s
1 and this point s 2 and the unit
vectors over here where R 1 and theta 1
when we're at the point as 2 we have to
choose unit vectors exactly the same way
our had two points in the direction of
increasing R and theta hat two points in
the direction of increasing theta so
what we see in polar coordinates is that
R hat one is not equal to R hat - why
are they not equal they both are unit
vectors so they both have the same
magnitude but they point in opposite
directions in the same way that theta
hat 1 is not equal to theta hat 2 so
unlike Cartesian coordinates in which at
every single point had the same unit
vectors in polar coordinates the unit
vectors depend on where you are in space
and that will make our analysis in polar
coordinates a little bit more
complicated